-Our first guest is one
of our absolute favorites.
He's very funny, very talented.
He stars alongside Paul Rudd
in a new series called
"The Shrink Next Door,"
which premieres this Friday
on Apple TV+.
Please welcome
the always entertaining,
the one and only Will Ferrell!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ "Don't Fear the Reaper"
plays ]
♪♪
-Wow!
-How you doing?
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
-[ Laughs ] Wow.
-Wow.
-The Roots in the house!
Oh, so good to be here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
-Uh...
R-Ryan -- Ryan Reynolds.
It is, uh --
-Oh, my God.
-It is -- Oh --
-Crazy, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So...
So weird.
-Yeah, I mean,
it is a little odd, yeah.
-I-I-I just
put the kids to bed.
-Yeah.
-I was walking the dog
around the block.
-Uh-huh.
-Will called.
-Okay.
-Said he was
running a little late.
-Okay.
-Asked me if I'd
jump in for him.
-Yeah.
-And I said,
"Anything for you, Will."
-Yeah.
-"I'm in."
-How late is Will running?
-Oh, he's gonna be here
in about a half past never.
Will's not coming.
[ Laughter ]
-Will's not coming at all.
-Will Ferrell's not here.
But -- But you're here.
This is amazing that --
-Yes, look.
I'm uncomfortable
with the word "hero," Jimmy,
but I am here.
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't call you a hero.
-I'm -- I'm just as disgusted
as you are with these --
these plastic, you know,
Playboy,
Hollywood prima donnas
that think they can just,
you know,
have a talk-show appearance
and then just not show up.
It's -- it's just --
Will Ferrell, too.
He loves late-night talk shows.
He's a late-night
talk-show slut.
Yet he just doesn't even --
Who blows this off?
He was like,
"Yeah, I can't make it."
It's just...
-Now that you're here, can --
I mean, how -- how --
how's Blake?
How's the kids?
-You know, they're all good.
Blake's -- no personal
questions, by the way.
But Blake is --
[ Laughter ]
Blake is -- is great.
The sex is totally normal.
-Okay. Wait. That's --
That's going --
I wasn't gonna ask that.
-Hey, hey, hey.
Pump -- Pump the sex brakes,
Jimmy.
I asked
no personal questions,
and you're going right in on it,
all right?
Barbara Walters, easy.
-Do I...?
-Easy does it.
[ Laughter ]
-I have all questions
for Will here.
-Well, fire away.
Look, I made a solemn swear
on the life of my children
that I would deliver this
for him 20 minutes ago,
and I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna talk
"The Shrink Next Door."
-Yeah, but do you want
to talk about --
You have a movie coming out
called "Red Notice"
with Dwayne Johnson.
-No, I don't want to talk --
No, guys, unh-unh, no.
No, we're not talking
about "Red Notice"
while I'm here.
-That's -- Okay.
-If you bring up "Red Notice,"
you will taste
the back of my hand.
-Wow!
-Just telling you right now.
-I'm gonna deliver...
-I've never even seen --
-...for Will Ferrell
because he is a golden god.
-Yeah.
-And that's what I'm gonna do.
-Well, you guys just did
a movie together.
-We did. We did a movie
called "Spirited," yeah.
-"Spirited," yeah.
And is that the first time
you've worked together?
-That is the second time.
We did a movie 20 years ago,
believe it or not, called
"Dick" -- I'm not making a joke.
It was about Richard Nixon.
Don't do personal --
And no personal questions.
-I promise,
and no personal questions.
I meant that.
And -- And again --
-Tell me about --
Tell me about "Dick."
-"Dick" --
[ Laughter ]
-Honestly, I don't remember.
The shrooms kicked in
right on time
when I was doing --
-All right.
Well, let's, uh --
Well, then let's -- let's talk
about "The Shrink Next Door."
-Yeah,
let's not make this weird.
-All right. Uh...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-"Shrink Next Door."
It's on Apple TV+.
-It is on Apple TV+.
It stars the great
Will Ferrell, Kathryn Hahn.
It's written
by Georgia Pritchett,
who you might know
from "Succession" and "Veep."
Incredible.
Paul Rudd.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Uh, I mean...
-This is great.
You actually did --
-This is -- Yes! Paul Rudd!
The Sexiest Man Alive.
I was gonna show this to Will,
but I'll show it to you.
-No, that's fine.
I'm happy for -- for Paul,
because, A, he's possibly
the nicest human being
in all of show business.
He's aging backwards because
of his contract with Satan.
[ Laughter ]
And, um...
Or he only drinks breast milk
from a blue whale or something.
-I heard about that.
-He does something weird.
-Yes, of course.
-And I want in.
-No, me too.
We all do -- we all want in
on whatever he's doing, yeah.
-Benjamin Buttons this life,
if we could.
-But let's --
"The Shrink Next Door" --
do you have really any idea
what the show is about?
-Oh, yeah.
It's, like -- It's sort of
an "Ant-Man" sequel.
It's like --
-No.
-It's in the "Ant-Man" universe.
-No, it's not.
No.
-It's "Ant-Man" adjacent.
"The Shrink Next Door"...
-Yeah.
-...is what I'm talking about.
-Yes, it's -- it's -- it's --
-Well, it's --
Yeah, he's a shrink, right?
He doesn't shrink, you know,
his body, per se,
but he's a psychiatrist,
so he does, like,
psychiatristy things.
-Paul is or Will is?
-No, no.
Paul is the psychiatrist.
He is the shrink in it, right?
-Okay, yeah.
-So, you know, he --
-He lives next door.
-Yes, he lives next door.
And he -- And he --
He minimizes himself
in relationships,
which is kind of like
"Ant-Man," right?
It's just --
It's just not --
It's more of like
a psychosomatic sort of --
-This is not a Marvel movie.
-It's Marvel Phase 16,
which everyone's saying is,
like, way more relatable.
So...
And period.
-It's a period piece?
-No-- Yes.
Yes, it is a period piece.
-Wow.
-Based on some of
the facial hair
that I have seen.
-All right.
-Yeah.
-And so Paul will
become patient and doctor.
-They crush it. Yeah.
-They really crush it.
-Paul has, like, a little lab
in his -- in his house,
and his kids are little rascals,
and he shrinks them by accident.
-Wait, wait.
The kids actually --
There is shrinking involved,
but he doesn't get shrunk.
And then he has to, like,
tell his wife, Kathryn Hahn...
-You have no idea
what this show is about.
-"Honey, I shrunk the kids."
No, that's
"Honey, I Shrunk the Kids."
And then they're all running
around in the blades of grass.
What's worse than terrible,
terrible swarms of bees, Jimmy?
I don't know what's worse than
terrible swarms of bees.
-This is on Apple TV+
-Right, yes, it is.
That much is 100% true.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to show a clip.
-I think we should definitely --
-Can you set up the clip for us?
-Yes. This will be a clip
where, you know,
Ant-Man and, um...
[ Laughter ]
We should just roll the clip.
-Okay, okay.
Here's Will Ferrell
and Paul Rudd
in "The Shrink Next Door."
Take a look at this.
-Excuse me, Marty?
Um, I'm Bonnie, Ike's wife.
-Bonnie!
Oh, my gosh. Hi.
-Hi.
-Hello.
-Oh.
I saw you standing alone.
And I'm not great
at these things, either.
-It is such a pleasure
to meet you.
Your husband,
what a great guy.
-He's...a great guy, yes.
Not necessarily a great dancer.
I haven't seen him have
this much fun since our wedding.
-He's really enjoying himself.
He sure has a lot of friends.
-Yeah, he does.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh.
Holy [bleep]
That's nothing
like "Ant-Man" at all.
-Ryan, you and I both agree
that people do a lot of things
that they have to stop doing.
-Yeah.
-So, with that in mind, it's
time for "You Have To Stop."
-Yeah.
-♪ Doo-boo-do-bo-do,
you have to stop ♪
-Hey.
You have to stop making plans
with me one month in advance.
I'm gonna say yes
because that does sound fun,
but when the day comes,
you know I'm gonna cancel
with some made-up excuse like,
"I'm not feeling well."
And that's not true.
I'm feeling great.
I just don't want
to leave my house tonight.
You have to stop.
[ Applause ]
-You have to stop whispering,
"That looks good,"
at the movies
after every trailer.
"Oh, that looks good."
We know it looks good.
That's --
That's the job of the trailer,
to make the movie look good.
Even bad movies
have good trailers.
I've been in some of them.
It's not impressive
when a trailer looks good.
They all look good. Stop.
Stop.
[ Applause ]
-You have to stop
checking TikTok real quick
before trying to fall asleep.
Oh, you got in bed
before midnight? Congrats.
Oh, you're checking TikTok
real quick?
Well, now it's 2:00 a.m.,
and you're watching
Ring Doorbell videos
of mailmen being surprised
with a basket of Clif bars.
So just stop. Please.
-Yeah. You have to stop
daylight saving time.
We're not farmers anymore.
The only thing
I've ever successfully grown
was this beautifully,
perfectly manicured beard.
And guess what. My kids don't
know what daylight savings is,
and now they're getting up
at 4:00 a.m.,
and I have to tell them
it's because of farmers.
So now my kids hate farmers.
I mean, you're creating
generations of kids
who hate farmers.
You have to stop!
[ Applause ]
-You have to stop
posting screenshots
with your phone battery on 1%.
I'm not looking
at what you posted.
I'm looking to see that
your phone needs to be charged!
Where are you?! Do you have
access to a phone charger?
Do you need to borrow one?
I'm sending help.
But you need to stop.
[ Applause ]
-And, you know, you have to stop
spending over ten minutes
scrolling for a TV show
or movie to watch.
I mean, if --
if you can't figure it out
after that amount of time,
you're never going to.
Just put on "The Great
British Baking Show"
and call it a night.
That's what it's there for.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You have to stop bringing back
the McRib, McDonald's.
It's not that the McRib is bad.
It's that you take it away,
and then you bring it back.
What if you did that
with other items?
"Sorry. No hamburgers
till next April.
This month, it's just fries."
That's no way
to run a restaurant.
So just leave the McRib
and please focus on something
more important like fixing
your ice-cream machines.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And, you know,
you have to stop saying
that you're gonna move to Canada
whenever you're mad
at something in the U.S.
As a Canadian,
I'm "sorry," but, no, you can't.
I know we're friendly, but
Canada's not your safe house.
I mean, we barely let Canadians
into Canada anymore.
So please...pick somewhere else.
I hear -- I hear Finland is
really lovely this time of year.
You have to stop.
-This has been
"You Have To Stop."
My thanks to Ryan Reynolds.